Here's a word.
And you're not going
to like this word--
failure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now here's the hitch.
It's OK to fail,
to feel insecure.
Now composers are
arrogant, especially when
we're talking about our music.
But the fact is, the
arrogance is generally
hiding great insecurity.
You have to let your ego go.
If you're smart, you're
really doing more listening
than talking.
You really aren't in charge.
The director's in charge.
Your job is to translate their
feelings about their movie
into music.
One more time.
Hearing the downbeat-- bomm.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the course of
this MasterClass,
we're going to talk
about instrumentation.
We're going to talk
about orchestration.
We're going to
talk about melody.
We're going to talk
about the tone.
The most important thing you're
going to capture in a film
score is going to be the tone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
"The Unknown Known"--
I tried to find a
very simple leitmotif.
Guitar-- there's
a mystery to it.
Ostinato begins, B section, and
it ends in a classical da da da
da da.
After a hundred and something films,
I'm constantly insecure.
Doubting yourself, finding
confidence and moving forward,
and then doubting what
you've just done--
I think this is the
life of a composer.
And I think it's the
life of an artist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you're really
going to succeed,
there's no other way but
by doing, making mistakes,
and then learning from those
mistakes and moving on.
If you take the time
and you learn it,
I promise you it'll
serve you well.
I'm Danny Elfman and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]